2026년 5월 4일 월요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 하락 마감했습니다.
기업들의 견주한 붕괴 시초에 따른 낙관놈보다는
이란과의 전쟁 격화 우려가 시양의 더 큰 악재로 작용했습니다.
이번 지정학적 긴장은 트럼프 대통령이 1월 호르무제협 통항 선박을 지원하는
프로젝트 프리돔을 발표하면서 본격화됐습니다.
트럼프 대통령은 해업 봉쇄로 발이 묶인 선박들이 무사히 빠져나올 수 있도록
미국이 돕겠다며 당장 월요일부터 이 계획을 실행하겠다고 밝혔습니다.
이에 이란은 미군이 해업 인근에 접근하면 즉각 타격하겠다고 경고하고 나섰습니다.
그러자 트럼프 대통령 역시 헉스 뉴스와의 인터뷰에서
이란이 미국 선박을 공격할 경우 지구상에서 흔적도 없이 날려버리겠다고 맞받아치며
긴장감을 한층 끌어올렸습니다.
양측의 강경 대응이 이어지는 가운데 아랍에미리트까지 이번 사태에 휘말렸습니다.
아랍에미리트는 이란에서 발사된 여러 발의 미사일을 요격했다고 밝혔는데
이는 지난달 미국과 이란의 휴전이 시작된 이후
아랍에미리트의 미사일 경보 시스템이 처음 작동한 사례입니다.
게다가 아랍에미리트 푸자이라항에서는 이란의 드론 공격으로 화재까지 발생했습니다.
여기에 이란이 미국 군함을 공격했다며
이란 구경TV는 이란 해군이 호르무즈에협 진입을 시도한 미국 군함을 차단했다고 전했고
파라스 통신은 미 군함이 경고를 무시하다가
자슥섬 인근에서 미사일 두 발에 피격됐다고 별도로 보도했습니다.
다만 두 보도 모두 사실관계가 확인되지 않은 상태였으며
이후 미 중부사령부가 미 해군 함정이 공격받은 사실이 없다고 공식 부인하며 사태를 일축했습니다.
호르무즈에협을 둘러싼 긴장이 고조되면서 에너지 가격 상승세가 이어졌고
글로벌 인플레이션을 자극할 수 있다는 우려에 국채의 금리도 급등했습니다.
장 초반 소폭 오르던 주가 지수 역시
아랍에미리트 푸자이라 석유산업단지 화재 보도가 나온 뒤 하락세로 돌아섰습니다.
결국 S&P500 지수는 0.41% 하락 마감했습니다.
종목별로는 게인스톱이 2배 인수를 제한했다는 소식에 게인스톱 주가가 10% 급락한 반면
게인스톱 주가가 10% 급락한 반면
이베이는 약 5% 상승했습니다.
아마존이 다른 기업들도 자사물류 네트워크를 이용할 수 있도록 하는
아마존 공급망 서비스를 출시한다는 소식에
UPS와 FedEx 주가는 하락했습니다.
버크셜스웨이는 실적 발표에서 14분기 연속 주식을 순매도했다고 밝혔습니다.
인프라스트럭처 캡털의 제이 하트필드는
우리는 전쟁이 빠르게 해결될 것으로 보지 않는다.
에드워드 존스의 제임스 맥켄은
이번 분쟁은 외교적 해법으로서
외교적 해법으로 마무리될 가능성이 크다.
다만 최근 몇 주간 시장이 가파르게 상승한 만큼
글로벌 에너지 시장에서 더 장기적이거나
더 큰 차질이 발생한 위험은 계속 주시해야 한다.
이 트레이드의 크리스 라키는
단기적으로 시장이 추가 상승하려면
중동발 부정적 돌변 변수를 피해야 한다.
라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 5월 5일 화요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제지표는
22시 30분 미국 3월 무역수준으로
22시 45분 미국 4월 S&P 글로벌 서비스업 PMI
22시 45분 미국 4월 S&P 글로벌 합성 PMI
23시 미국 4월 ISM 서비스업 PMI
23시 미국 3월 신규 주택 판매
23시 미국 3월 졸트 구인 인원
23시 연준 보호문 부의장
공안시 30분 연준 바이사가 예정되어 있습니다.